our speaker tonight is one of the most
versatile and broad-ranging authors in
the world today
Ian Wilson has published at least 16
novels that I'm aware of and I asked him
earlier if I had the count ride he said
he doesn't count so who knows how many
how many novels I have left out of that
that count but among them are such
titles as kindly light the healing art
wise virgin The Vicar of Sorrows my name
is legion and a jealous ghost many of us
know him primarily for his 18 volumes of
nonfiction mr. Wilson has written
biographies of such figures as Jesus of
Nazareth Nazareth the Apostle Paul John
Milton Sir Walter Scott Leo Tolstoy CS
Lewis and Iris Murdoch he has devoted
several books to religious and
philosophical questions with such titles
as how can we know the church in crisis
against religion why we should live
without it and God's funeral a biography
of faith and doubt in Western
civilization he has chronicled what he
refers to as the rise and fall of the
House of Windsor he supplied us with a
charming history of London and he has
devoted to significant studies to the
Victorians
according to William H Pritchard who
reviewed the more recent of these
studies for the Chicago Tribune mr.
Wilson is incapable of writing a dull
sentence and he appears to have read
everything of pertinence to his vast
subject our own Michael Durda of the
Washington Post concurs with this
judgment whether he's discussing
religious doubt or cholera the Crystal
Palace or Darwinism
pre-raphaelite paintings or the crimean
war wilson sweeps the reader along in
this magnificent contribution to popular
scholarship we're happy to note that mr.
Wilson has now turned his attention to
what happened after the Victorians and
that is the title of the book that will
be our focus tonight and it's an honor
to welcome him for what I know will be a
memorable account of what made the first
half of the 20th century such a
traumatic period in our history mr.
Wilson well thank you very very much
indeed for that gracious introduction
John and thank you too and and thank you
all of you for welcoming me to the
Women's National Democratic Club it's a
great pleasure to be here and a great
honor to be here I was amused to think
of the fourth of July can you hear is
the microphone working is this the one
that so I always think with microphones
of that moment in Evelyn was the ordeal
of Gilbert pin filled when the voices
begin speaking to him and he grabs a
lamp in the middle of the the table of
shouts pin fell to hooligans painful to
hooligans over and out but some not
there's anybody in this room is a
hooligan of course is this alright I'm
rather worried by the inaudible is he
can you hear at the back you chair no
toward the valance excellent or I might
not be but at least at least is what
you've come for
I was amused to think of those of my
fellow countrymen who are onto the
impression that the 4th of July was
Thanksgiving it reminded me of an
occasion when I was at Oxford and used
to have dining rights on the high table
of my college where I taught new college
whether there are other members present
we remember that institution and the
distinguished professor from the
University of Ohio came to dinner and
when he said who he was where he came
from one of the English professors lean
forward helpfully and said we pronounce
it Iowa
anyway Here I am not in Iowa or in Ohio
and having a very nice time unlike John
Maynard Keynes was one of the characters
who occurs in this book and who made
frequent visits to the United States to
try to persuade Henry Morgenthau jr. the
US Secretary of the Treasury to part
with cash which was not something he did
very willingly and certainly not without
great many conditions attached which was
one of the themes of my book Keynes
remarked after one such interview that I
have seldom struck anything stickier and
when he got back to London he said I
always regard a visit to the United
States of America that's in the nature
of serious illness to be followed by a
long period of convalescence I haven't
ever felt that in fact I always find it
very stimulating to be on American soil
this morning I came down from New York
but before I left New York I went to see
what had happened to the Episcopalian
cathedral which as you know had a
terrible fire a few years ago and I
hadn't seen it since the fire very much
loved acquaintances of mine that
compares of Virgil Thompson used to
refer to it as st. John the - to divine
and it still looks to to divine I stood
in the corner which is devoted to the
memory of American writers and poets and
I was wondering what I was going to say
to you this evening and I gaze down at
the tablets in memory of gratitude Stein
a figure whom I revere but with a pinch
of salt perhaps and I was uplifted to
read the words which presumably she
wrote let me recite what history teaches
history teaches
I don't know I think it's slightly
better than a rose is a rose is a rose
but my problem both with this book and
with what I have to say this evening is
the question yes of course it teaches
but what does it teach and what if
anything do we learn from the whole
progress of human history from the early
19th century up to the present time
because I do feel that the title of this
book
after the Victorians which I have to
confess you I reached after thinking of
lots of other titles which didn't seem
entirely satisfactory and it seemed
rather a feeble title in a way actually
describes our condition both in the
first half of the 20th century and at
the present time very accurately when I
was further thinking what to say or
rather how to arrange my thoughts
tonight i sat on the excellent Amtrak
train now I gather around a new
management and I read this letter in the
Wall Street Journal it's from a a
gentleman in Florida his name is Barry
Allen brown brown eyes and it's about
the question of world capitalism I won't
read it all but it's announced that some
debate that's been going on in that
newspaper about Francis Fukuyama's idea
of the differences between European
culture and the United States and mr.
Elden brown or Oren Brown writes as
Hayek and his disciples have pointed out
capitalism is the most democratic and
virtuous of social systems dollars are
not black white or red and a society
that had toward social and cultural
respect to those who succeed in the
economic sphere is by definition more
inclusive than one based on any other
set of criteria
I was very interested by that letter it
was a very vigorously expressed letter
it's much longer than that paragraph
would suggest because it's occurred to
me that it could easily have been
written in the year 1844 by a
self-confident northern liberal in
England rejoicing over the abolition of
tariffs or the Corn Laws as they were
called and the extension of free trade
as you all know the idea of free trade
really was the rallying cry of Victorian
liberalism both in the economic and the
political sense of the word and if the
Victorians gave anything to the world
and of course they gave many things I
think the primary thing that they gave
to the world was the idea of extending
trade free trade throughout the globe
and with it they believed extending
political Liberty they believed that the
two went hand in hand and they believed
also that political Liberty was of
course wherever it was to be found
whether it was to be found in India or
in America or in Africa
later stages should in fact just be a
mirror image of what was happening in
London or anyway in the United Kingdom
now what strikes me so forcibly reading
that letter today coming from Florida is
how strongly a great many people in the
United States was would read with its
author and also how many people in
England fewer I think perhaps in France
and Germany but certainly it's one of
the things which unites the British and
the Americans this belief that trade and
the political systems which tend to go
with world free trade or what's now
called globalization go hand-in-hand
it's still a debate which is very very
much with us and I want to explore it a
little bit if I may that's one of the
themes just announced that Jared Stein
that I want
talk about which I feel is a lesson I
don't quite know what the answer is and
it might come out in the questions
afterwards rather than what I say
initially from the podium is one of
these lessons left behind from the
Victorian legacy the other great issue
which faced the Victorians and about
which I've already written two books
really one the one called God's funeral
which is not a as you might have
gathered from the introduction a kind of
atheist rent but very far from it it's
an allusion to Thomas Hardy's poem in
which he imagines this melancholy
procession following behind a coffin
it's really a kind of dream poem and he
realizes as he follows the procession
that it is the 19th century putting the
almighty to rest it's a kind of very
gentle version of nature's much more
hysterical claims in his writings that
question the question of what the world
does with or without religion is also
very very much with us and I would have
thought that for many Americans and
certainly for many British people today
there's two very Victorian questions
whether free trade and the democratic
systems of government which tend to go
with it can orchid or should be extended
throughout the world and what we do
about the religious question are two
questions which the Victorians may have
thought they solved and they thought
they laid to rest but which are two
questions very very much with us today
and particularly in this country I just
want to think about them a little as we
spend some time together this evening as
I was writing this book it would have
been perfectly possible of course to
deal with those two questions and the
ones would relate to them entirely
theoretically historiography
is the subject which has drawn through
very many changes over the last hundred
hundred fifty years going back to Hegel
really who believed that history was a
great force moved by inexplicable
spirits of time and if you happened to
be in one era of history then you were
bound to be moved by one particular
Geist and if you moved out of another
era you would be judged by a different
Geist Karl Marx who was really a hog
alien took this up and defines this
spirit in economics and materialist
terms of course suggesting that if you
have the right situation in economic
terms the right number of particular
guilds in Italy let us say the right
amount of gold being borrowed in Genoa
here the right amount of money being
needed there that you're going to end up
absolutely inevitably and ineluctably
with pope julius ii commissioning
Michelangelo to paint the Sistine Chapel
to meet such determinist interpretations
of history have never been entirely
satisfactory because I think that human
nature mercifully always gets in the way
of such theories and I've written my
books this one and the previous one
called the Victorians with an almost
conscious decision not to be guided by
philosophical or political theories of
any kind but rather to see the
experiences of our in this case parents
and grandparents generation in the case
of the Victorians a much earlier
generation to see these things in terms
of human experience and so if somebody
reads one of my books and considers it
to be a cat a lot of gossip and anecdote
I should feel very happy rather than
considering to be clever cleverness is
something which I've tried without very
much difficult to avoid in this book I
think
over this question of free trade and
democracy and then and then I'll think a
little bit about the religious question
and then we perhaps generalize about the
about the two and how they affect one
another
I spent a vast amount of time reading
for this book and wondering how I was
going to bring everything together and
the more one thought about it the more
one realized that one of the central
figures in the whole story was President
Wilson and his vision of the world which
again is very much topical and very much
with us because so many people believe
that a Wilsonian package for the world
is still something which is a viable
proposition and something which if it
were exported would bring peace and joy
even if it's exported under protest and
I then read an article by Robert
Skidelsky which I think was published in
the New Statesman in January 2004 which
focused my mind completely on what it
was about the 20th century which made it
unlike any other in my mind though
perhaps it's just more like how there's
only more surf though if that doesn't
sound too peculiar and it's this that in
previous ages people more or less wanted
a certain thing and then set out to get
it and they more or less achieved what
they wanted it may be that what they
wanted turned out to be a horrible thing
as in the case of the French terror but
they got what they wanted whereas I
think in the 20th century the political
and social choices facing people very
often led not merely to the precise
opposite of what anybody had wanted but
somehow or another had written into them
the possibility of tragedy farce it's a
hard word to use tragedy files when so
many people in the 20th century
and suffered and whether at the
receiving end of appalling political
regimes but when you think of President
Wilson and when you think of the people
who supported his aim and continue to do
so to bring national independence and
self-determination to as many people on
the face of the planet as possible it's
very hard to think that that is not is
anything other than the most noble
possible aspiration for the human race
and that is what the people discussing
these matters at the Versailles Treaty
at the end of the first world war were
trying to do to the peoples of the
Balkans to the Irish to the peoples of
the Middle East and eventually of course
to the peoples of South America as well
what happened during the First World War
was that the Imperial ideal was put to
rest and above all the Ottoman Empire
was got rid of as we all know what
skewed Elstree in this article Lucia
which I read reminds us is that once you
remove the umbrella of an empire of an
Imperium of a group of Nations who
willy-nilly have to live together a
group of people who have to live
together regardless of their ethnic
their religious their social their
historical differences what is your
definition of a nation and the first
nation to emerge after the collapse of
the Ottoman Empire was one which emerged
of course before the First World War it
was Turkey and the Young Turks who
preceded Ataturk as the revolutionaries
who created the modern state of Turkey
decided that the criterion which would
determine what a new modern nation-state
was was race genocide
became and this was the point of the
street Elstree article where does
genocide come from genocide came about
as a direct consequence of the young
turks belief that they should be an
independent non imperialist nation-state
and as we all know the Armenians were
the ones who suffered in that particular
experiment it's still rather shockingly
it still regularly denied by Turkish
authorities that the Armenian massacres
took place but most historians believe
that something approaching a million
people were killed as the Turkish state
was set up and as Hitler memorably and
chillingly throughout during one of his
rants at the dinner table recorded by
one of his lackeys in that book called
Hitler's table told who now remembers
the Armenians what's so shocking about
the twentieth century or were there many
shocking things but one of the very
shocking things I think about the
twentieth century is that the peoples
who sought to put it if you like it a
wilsonian veldt politique a will sown in
idea into practice invariably came
across this racialist
question how do you define a nation if
you if you give up being an empire the
British at the end of the story and we
all know all too well the the the
terrible massacres which took place
throughout this period but if you take
it to the end of the story as I do in my
book
the British pull out from India the
British having stayed in India too long
as everybody recognizes now got art was
indecent haste and one of the things
that they wish to bring to the Indians
or helped to bring to the Indians was
democracy
well that was all very well if you
happen to be in the hindu-majority
but what was going to happen to you if
you belong to the Muslim minority
democracy would be the greatest stress
that were possibly afflict you and once
again a terrible thing to contemplate
when you think of the numbers of people
who'd been killed in the mean time in
the First World War in the Second World
War in the quad rooms indeed in the
Holocaust in the mass starvation's in
the Soviet Union in all the deaths in
the duel and that after all that
Massacre the well-meaning though
criminally careless British
administration in India should lead to
well over a million deaths at the time
of partition so that's one of the
questions which I put two dirt road
Stein and to myself and I can't answer
for you what lesson do we learn from the
fact that although we want people to be
self-determining and although we want
people to be democratic and although we
want to bring these blessings to other
peoples in the world how do we square it
with the historical fact that almost
every country that's traded it has led
to a disaster there's another question
and that's the the religious question
and I'm sure there are many other things
we could be talking about including
science and literature and all sorts of
elevating by all means ask questions
about those after we're in a book which
is out of fashion now but I very much
enjoyed rereading for this for the
purposes of writing this book the Seven
Pillars of wisdom by TE Lawrence
Lawrence of Arabia explains why he found
the Bedouins and the Arabs in general
such an attractive people and he said it
was because they did not suffer from
doubt which he added is our modern crown
of thorns
now it's a very memorable phrase and it
used to stay in my head a lot as I went
about thinking doubt our mantra of
nausea so it's absolutely right of
course it is this and then I thought
back over all my friends that I had made
while I was writing my Victorian books
and thought hang on TE Lawrence this is
not right at all when you think of
tennyson believing where he cannot prove
in in memoriam when you think of the
prince albert infinitely the most
attractive I was gonna say British royal
but of course that's precisely what he
wasn't but in history all these people
what the Victorians had both in the
political sphere and in the Victor and
in the religious sphere was the capacity
to live with doubt that was precisely
that one of their strengths Matthew
Arnold whom we were talking about at the
dinner table was a man who built his
life on the shifting sands of doubt and
found it was a very strong house at the
end of the 19th century
of course there had been this divide
between those who felt that modern
biblical scholarship scientific research
but primarily into geology people think
nowadays that Darwin showed people's
religious faith I don't think that's
particularly true most of the great
Darwinian xand most of the great
biologists and botanists of the 19th
century were very devout Christians what
shook people's faith I think in the
scientific sphere in that period as
Tennyson's poetry shows was Lyell though
Lyle was himself a religious believer so
Charles Lyell's discovery that the world
was infinitely older than the Bible had
said it was and we all remember
sometimes rather patronizingly perhaps
Edmund Ross's father and son and his
brilliant though tormented father Philip
Rous who was both a scientist and
a very extreme what we would call
fundamentalist who came up with the
ingenious theory that possibly the
fossils had been placed in the stonework
by the Almighty in order to test our
faith but that the dating of the the
planet could still be according to the
rather bizarre dating which was not even
in the Bible but was imposed on the
Bible by an archbishop of armagh called
Archbishop Ussher in the 17th century
why this should be regarded as a matter
of such profound religious importance
that everybody has to believe in it as
an astral of faith I don't know but
anyway I think that the glorious thing
about the 19th century was the capacity
to live with doubt and I think it was
one of their really great qualities you
get it in Emerson you get it in Carlisle
you get it in Tennyson as I've already
said you read it in many of the great
scientists and one of the really
exciting things about the Roman Catholic
Church towards the end of the 19th
century beginning of the 20th was the
number of people particularly in France
who realized that a modern understanding
of religion and a modern understanding
of science were not necessarily
incompatible well as we know that the
Pope's of the period did not agree with
those people and they were very firmly
stamped upon but the so called modernist
movement was regarded as a terrible
heresy I think what you can see
happening in the world that he has TE
Lawrence describes very far from being
down to being the modern crown of thorns
is a terrible certainty overcoming
people and to tell you the truth
although I enjoyed writing this book I
came to hate the period with a kind of
loathing so great that it almost felt
like having a kind of nervous breakdown
whenever I returned to the writing table
in the morning because I knew that you
know what Dorothy Parker said when she
picked up the post from the coconut
matting what fresh horror is here but um
well knew that there was going
a terrible fresh horror with every
country and with every unfolding
miserable year of the years 1900 and 1
to 1945 political certainty in areas
where no certainty was justified at all
insane followings of doctrines both in
Germany and in Russia - with terrible
consequences which we all know about
very very well and of course in the
aftermath of the Indian troubles and the
aftermath of what happened in the Middle
East after the Second World War a
resurgence of terrifying irrational
Islamic hate-filled fundamentalism which
we are living with to this hour it's
true in the list of books and it is true
I'd never remember what what I've
written but in the list of books read
out at the beginning was a small
pamphlet I once wrote called against
religion it doesn't mean as I am against
religion but it for the purposes of
argument in that pamphlet which I wrote
at the time when Salman Rushdie had been
condemned to death I voiced the view
that some of the religious leaders in
the world seem more inspired by hate
than anything else and that there was
something particularly ridiculous about
feeling that you always had to apologize
to people for fear of offending their
so-called religious sensibilities I
think in a free society you should be
allowed to debate ideas whether they're
offensive to people or not that was the
point of my pamphlet but I think one of
the really troubling things one of the
really travelling lessons this is the
second point that I drew from this
period was that doubt that very useful
function was a capacity which the human
race seemed to lose as they moved into
the confrontations of the 30s they lost
it in
little sphere and they lost it in the
religious sphere too and if only a few
more people had had the courage of for
example the German theologians who
unpicked the whole of the New Testament
and regarded it as a kind of mythology
but nonetheless held on deeply to what
they considered to be the important
things in the Christian religion or had
the courage of Mahatma Gandhi who
realized the fundamental importance of
the spiritual impulse in human beings
but tried to dissuade people with a
Hindu Muslim Sikh or Christian from
hating well another if a little more of
that had been going on not merely on
popular levels but among senior
religious figures and among theologians
and thinkers and philosophers the world
would perhaps not now be facing some of
the rather terrifying religious
confrontations which it is both
obviously the engagements within Islam
between the extremists and the huge
majority were not murderers but also
within the West this is really very
troubling development I think which
seems to suggest that the only people
who can nowadays be regarded as
Christians are fundamentalists and as if
you can't for example introduce the
Bible into I'm not now referring to the
state of Kansas in its travels
particularly Liberty in general if you
can't introduce the Bible into the
scientific lesson that that seems to me
a very very dangerous development and so
I'd like to end this little bit of the
proceedings by reading a tiny bit if I'm
allowed to do that of my book or a
truncated version I want to talk about
the deaths of Bonhoeffer in Germany and
in India because they strike me as two
very very helpful signs for the world
Bonhoeffer as you probably know was a
theologian he was a young rather normal
person to be a theologian miss the
illusions are slightly cracked but he
was a perfectly normal person it was
really surprising development in his
life his father having a psychologist he
was a rich man by the standards of
people in the 1920s and 1930s in Germany
rather dressy heterosexual which was
again unusual for deeply religious men
not unknown but unusual and he had this
vision of Christianity as something
which was vitally important his family
didn't share it they weren't hostile to
his vision but he headed and it's
strange to think of him when he was in
his 20s going to London to be the the
German pastor of one of the churches
there and having these long lunches with
a man called Bishop bell in the
Athenaeum Club where all these Victorian
agnostics and Anthony Trollope had had
their lunch in days before it's nice to
think of their shades and ghosts people
like Thomas Huxley and
Matthew Arnold himself hovering around
as bell and Bonhoeffer had their lunch
as you probably know Bonhoeffer
predicted in 1932 before the rise of
Hitler that it ultimately those people
who held to his view of life and to the
view of life which most Christian people
in Germany held through namely that
there should be no distinction between
people on grounds of race or class or
riches or gender would ultimately have
to pay for this with their lives he then
wrote what I think is one of the most
important books of the 20th century his
book on ethics which was never published
in his lifetime in which he departed
from
purest ethical view and realized there
were occasions in life when life was so
awful that you had to get your hands
dirty and he became involved with the
plot the Gothenburg blocks to
assassinate Hitler and was part of the
huge number of people who are eventually
rounded up and a few weeks before the
end of the war he was hanged and I just
want to allude to that here by saying it
was a martyrdom a witnessing was
standing out with tremendous simplicity
against not only the evil but also the
profound absurdity of National Socialism
it was also a standing out I think
against all the conflicts which had been
waged in politics and on the battlefield
for the last 45 years the prison doctor
who saw him die was struck not only by
his love ability but by an extraordinary
serenity in his face as he approached
the hangman three years later or little
less than three years later Mahatma
Gandhi faced the assassin in Delhi and
over his funeral pyre Nehru said those
famous words the light which shone in
this country it was no ordinary light he
was right I think inspired by Tolstoy
very largely also by his reading of the
bhagavad-gita Gandhi again a man who
hadn't started out as a particularly
religious person had ever since he began
his career as a lawyer in South Africa
been a man who felt himself naturally
contra mundum he was naturally in in
opposition that was his normal position
and his dogged defiance of the British
Empire was on one level I think a
triumph of simple rationalism he wasn't
appealing to some spurious notion of
democracy or racial purity or any of the
other noxious mythologies which
ripped human minds during this period he
appealed very simply as his master
Tolstoy had done to the knowledge that
inside every human being there is a
conscience there's a consciousness of
what is good and what is evil and it
doesn't really require any mumbo-jumbo
or creed or cleverness to urge us to a
serene knowledge of this point of view
of course you could say that Gandhi's
campaigns for Indian independence were
just the kind of political struggle as I
was talking about earlier which led to
such terrible trouble but I think that
it's be truer to say that Gandhi like
Bonhoeffer wasn't really interested in
politics as such at all I think he saw
that nation-states and dictatorships and
empires and tyrants and Parliament's
ultimately have no real capacity to
bring the human race happiness his last
word was not a political one it was Rama
one of the incarnations of Vishnu I've
been doing on slightly longer than I
thought so I'm just trying to say one
further thing yeah one of the the
writers that I hope to resurrect in this
book is a novelist troll John Hooper
Parris who spent a lot of his time in
the United States he was a Welshman in
origin and he died in Wales at the age
of about 95 but one of the books which
most impressed me which I hadn't read
before I did this but was the book which
was published in 1951 it's a long long
long novel about the times of King
Arthur and it's trawled poorest and he
gives to Merlin this rather wonderful
speech nobody in the world nobody beyond
the world can be trusted with power and
I think if I were
Gertrude Stein and her shade I would say
that was what my lesson for the 20th
century was nobody in the world can be
trusted his power the Gerald an age can
never come again till governments and
rulers and kings and emperors and
priests and druids and gods and devils
learn to unmake themselves and leave men
and women to themselves and I think
that's really what we all dream of when
we want self-determination for nations
what we actually want is
self-determination for women and men and
children as individuals and I don't
think we've quite dropped there yet
next - Jared Stein's tablet in the
cathedral there's one for Elizabeth
Bishop to me a more impressive figure
and her little correlation rather moving
is all the untidy activity continues
awful but cheerful I think that more or
less sums up what I feel
thank you very much
wonderful thank you so very very much I
invite all of you to write your
questions down on cards and people will
bring them up and we'll do the best we
can to get them answered here Yates said
the best lack all conviction
it was Yeats yes Yeats said the best
lack all conviction would the world have
been better off if believers in
democracy in the 30s had strong
convictions did you did you all hear
yeah well I mean the trouble with the
thirties there were thousands of
troubles with the thirties but I see
where the questioner is coming from what
they are suggesting is that if there
have been a stronger move from the
Democratic countries then the tyrants
and the what Maynard Keynes rightly
called the brigand states would have
been held in check but I'm afraid to say
that hardly one doesn't do very well
which was the trouble with the 1930s in
Western Europe not in Eastern Europe was
that Germany was a democracy and Adolf
Hitler was not although he liked to
speak of his grasp of power and his
cease seizure of power and it's
certainly true that his seizure of power
within the cabinet was pretty shady he
was elected he dropped there by
Democratic means and I'm fairly sure
that after a year in power although he
actually abolished elections as we know
had he stood for election he would have
been reelected with thunderous majority
so that one is in a problem they're
thinking about were democracies as such
if by that you mean do decent country
whatever they may be did they do enough
the trouble is when you look at the
borders what would they have done it
becomes it's I'm not being a revisionist
here and of course the British
government in particular behaved
deplorable throughout the 1930s
absolutely deplorable and Churchill
almost alone with a very small band of
friends reminded them in season and out
of season of how badly they were
behaving and how stupid they were being
of course there were things which would
have been done but what couldn't have
been done is what was dreamed of by some
of the Germans who were horrified by
what was going on in their own country
of an actual invasion or a a takeover
who would have done it you couldn't have
got through Switzerland you couldn't
have got through Austria the real that
the real key to the whole question as we
all see now with in retrospect was
Czechoslovakia it was a thriving
industrial democracy bang in the middle
of Europe and it was on Hitler's
doorstep and he wanted it and instead of
realizing that the Czechoslovakian army
it would have been extremely dangerous
against the German army had been United
with the British and the French Neville
Chamberlain with an act of criminal
folly went and offered it to Hitler as a
chip on the card table and such a thing
is a perpetual blot on the memory of of
Great Britain I'm afraid to say
in retrospect was there any logical
rationale for the post Victorians to
establish Iraq as a nation oh well here
is a very topical question when you read
I put this in my book too when you read
of how Iraq became a nation with Winston
Churchill Lawrence the REA bear and a
few cronies don't spend in the drebbel
wheat you know in an Egyptian hotel
Churchill doing a little bit of painting
said when he went out in the streets
everybody shouted in the eldest
interests in those days everybody hated
him
this group of Europeans calmly deciding
what Lawrence's former friends and
comrades in arms in the first world war
should be offered as a little reward for
their part in the revolution as as
Lawrence himself admitted it was only a
sideshow the the Bedouins
the Bedouin help against the Turkish
army the main work had been done by the
Australians as a matter of fact and also
by the mainstream Arab armies but they
offered to Faisal the possibility of
becoming a king in Iraq and his his
kinsmen was given the Kingdom of Jordan
and they simply sat down with a pencil
and a map and they drew out this border
with the consequences that we are still
living with I'm afraid but of course it
would be naive to pretend that they were
doing it for some reason for reasons of
romanticism as you all know I'm sure in
about 1908 the Germans built a railway
stretching from Berlin and going through
what's now Turkey and eventually
reaching Baghdad itself and this was one
of the determining features of British
horror and paranoia which led to the
first world war there's no question
about that
that at a time in history when power
depended entirely on navies the British
Navy
could be said to have won the war for
the British before certainly held the
the war in the British balance before
the intervention of the Americans the
British Navy led to the deaths of 85,000
German civilians during their terrible
winter of starvation 1915 to 16 when the
British Navy blockaded the German ports
the so called tonic winter from the
Germans navies were absolutely crucial
and in that period before the First
World War they'd stopped being fueled by
coal and they become fuelled by this new
material which have been discovered and
developed and the Basra oil fields
became absolutely central and the
British as the Americans were quickly
become themselves were obsessed by the
bath or oil fields Churchill would do
anything to hold on to them as we know
and it could be said that some of some
of the less credible science of
Churchill's life are shown up in his
attitude to Iraq we also of course
discover in Iraq a very troubling thing
because after the kingdom had been set
up the British wondered how many troops
they would need this again is a rather
topical question to keep the place
stable because they had very foolishly
and we were still living with this but
three totally incompatible people's the
Kurds and the Sunnis and the Shiites all
to live together and they discovered the
man who became known as bomber Harris at
a later stage of his career and the
other trench rod and the other Royal Air
Force officers discovered that it was
much cheaper rather than putting men on
the ground to control these people by
bombardment from the air and in the case
of the small villages there that worked
but the whole story of the British
intervention in Iraq which was to do
with their obsession with India and
holding on to India and fueling the
Royal Navy is one of those disaster
areas which I'm for unfortunately has
made in England
on the bottom like so many other things
in this world it doesn't give me any
pleasure at all to say that I'm not one
of those people who enjoy dwelling on
the faults of my country in its recent
past but it really is a disaster with
which we're still living and the answer
is is more or less everything probably
but we shouldn't which would come back
to that one thing which I think efforts
ought to expand upon how much were these
20th century horrors outcrops of
Victorian values if you want to call it
that one which is I think undoubtedly a
product of the Victorian legacy is
racialism and this particular poisonous
form of racialism which you get
developed in germany but is by no means
confined to germany but i think the
reason it was so terrifying
apart from the fact we know what
happened as a result of it is that it
was based upon rather than being based
upon whim or prejudice or sheer
nastiness
it was supposedly based on science and
even Charles Darwin a great and good man
towards the end of his career with his
beliefs in the descent or descent and
ascent of man comes very near to some of
the nastier Nazi debate developments
into ideas of human character and human
racial characteristics believing that
Europeans for example have larger brains
than Africans which is suppose from
perhaps
rubbish or believing that they that the
Africans are in a kind of more primitive
state than the rest of us and so on and
so forth all these ridiculous as well as
noxious views how did such a thing come
about at the time of the Indian Mutiny
as the Indian as the English called it
there were dreadful reprisals after that
moment in 1857 8 when various Indian see
poised members of the army had refused
to bite the cartridges or of the guns
they pins send because they contained
animal fats which they weren't allowed
to eat according to their religion Queen
Victoria to her very great credit after
the reprisals began complained and said
it had to stop and said that the Queen
wants it to be known that she takes very
great exception to what we would call
racialism and she said that it was never
had been part of the Queen's belief this
one person it was to be distinguished
from another person on the grounds of
the color of their skin or their
religion or their racial origin
it's my perhaps sentimental belief that
there always was the decent British
relief hence Samuel Johnson Tory of
Tories in the 18th century
cheering when he heard that the slaves
in the Jamaican plantations had rebelled
but with the growth of and this is
another thing which I'm afraid we have
to face about the the growth of free
trade with the growth of the Empire
which grew out of a British trade
expansion came this belief that the the
white settlers particularly in Africa of
course these beliefs became strong but
also in India were superior by virtue of
their greater wealth and when it came to
this whole package of the extraordinary
beliefs which were quite news of the
human race they really believed that I
think that is it's absolutely natural
and normal for people to fear strangers
and not to like their next-door
neighbors and to extend that
country's next door to one another
always dislike one another and that's in
a sense good clean fun and Greeks and
Trojans will always be at war of course
they will but it's a very different
thing I think from saying that the
scientifically speaking Trojans are an
inferior or lesser breed or a subhuman
breed and the Greeks and superior and
that's something which we see emerging
as a direct transference of economic
superiority but dressed up as a bit of
science boat of science thank you so
very very much
[Applause]